es el décimo día de protestas en Francia
y la resistencia de la ciudadanía
francesa contra la reforma de pensiones
no parece aflojar en París las
manifestaciones transcurrieron
tranquilamente en su mayoría pero entre
la Plaza de la República y la de la
nación estalló la tensión con
enfrentamientos con la policía que Rocío
a los manifestantes con gases en
lacrimógenos esta mañana ha estado en un
piquete en Clermont los trabajadores
están decididos cuando los escuchas
hablar sobre su trabajo comprendes
inmediatamente que trabajar dos años más
no es posible esa es la realidad en
otras ciudades como nantes en o burdeos
también se congregaron decenas de miles
de personas en diferentes puntos del
país se registraron decenas de detenidos
y medidas cuestionables por parte de la
policía como el uso de cañones de agua
el gobierno que se muestra decidido a no
ceder en su decisión de aumentar en la
edad de jubilación de los 62 a los 64
años parece proclive al diálogo tras la
presión en las calles
el presidente ha hecho que está
dispuesto a reunirse con los sindicatos
una vez que el consejo constitucional se
haya pronunciado sobre la validez del
proyecto de ley la primera ministra
también está a disposición de los
sindicatos para reunirse directamente
con ellos y dialogar
en esta jornada cerca de 750.000
personas salieron a manifestarse y a no
ser que se ofrezca alguna modificación
en la ley los sindicatos aseguran que
ellos tampoco van a ceder